[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God the
Israel.
>> First, I want to thank everybody for
having their patience being out here
enduring this rain. Give yourselves a
hand.
>> We had to endure the rain. That's
Christians and Israelites, atheists,
whoever it is. I'm Captain Zario. Good
under command of Jenny Hana. Today, um
debate is is Jesus the most high God. Uh
my position is that he's not the most
high God.
>> There may be verses that will say that
um he's a god or imply that, but there's
no verse that's going to say he's the
most high God. You can't have a most
high god and then he has a god. You
cannot present that. So that'll be what
I'll be presenting today.
>> Uh this will end up being a semantic
argument. You'll see we'll just be going
over verses that my opponent will imply
means he's the most high, but it won't
say it flat out. So that's what I'm
going to present. I yield.
Real quick, uh, before you go, fellas,
please don't engage these speakers.
Like, don't try to debate them while
they debate. You know what I'm saying?
So, you could you could scream, you
could say that, you could do whatever.
>> You can clap. You can clap and do all of
that.
>> But don't try to engage. You know what
I'm saying? Let don't try to engage. Let
them debate. All right? You can debate
them afterwards if you like. Okay?
>> Yeah. Michael Jones. I run Inspiring
Philosophy, a YouTube ministry. Uh, my
position is Jesus is the most high God
in terms of something. Right. Right.
[Applause]
>> Hold up. Hold on.
>> All right. Now listen up. This is the
important. We are trinitarians as
Christians. We believe there is one God
who is three persons. The father, the
father is the source for the son and the
spirit. But the spirit and the son share
in the divine essence or substance.
Therefore making them the exact imprint
of the father. Especially Jesus. Hebrews
1:3 says that. So Jesus is the most high
God in terms of substance. What I expect
my opponent to do is go to verses where
it talks about him being subordinate
role. Subordinate role. We refer to that
to the economic structure of the
trinity, not the autological structure
of the trinity because in the onlogical
structure of the trinity, Jesus is fully
and totally God.
>> Therefore, he is the most high God. And
so I expect we'll go through some of
those verses and look into them. But we
have to make sure when we look at those
verses, are they talking about role or
ontology? I will argue those are in
ontology. And there are explicit places
where Jesus does claim he is Yahweh, who
is the most high God.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, you guys. So, as soon as
either of you guys start talking, I'm
going to press that start and I'll stop
you guys. Uh
>> I'll give you guys a a 30 minute warning
>> and then after that, you guys got
>> All right. Captain, appreciate you being
here.
>> Likewise.
>> Appreciate it. Uh, so is Yahweh the most
high God?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Who led Israel out of Egypt?
>> Moses.
>> Moses. By who?
>> By the most high.
>> By the most high. Yeah. Hosea 12:13.
Yahweh let him out. So, definitely.
There we go. What's Jude say?
>> When you think about that, right, in
Exodus 71, God called Moses God, right?
>> Called him Elohim.
>> Did he call him Elohim? I'm fine with
that. But he called him when we read it
in English, he called him God, right?
>> Yes. We want to be I want to be clear
about something though. The word Elohim
doesn't properly translate to God
because when Samuel is dead, the
necromancer uh brings up the the body of
Samuel from Shil and he says, "I see
Elohim coming up." So scholars like
Michael Heiser will say the word Elohim
much broader meaning. It refers to
anything in the spiritual realm, demons,
angels, God of the word, right? It means
judges, ruler, angels, possibly there's
debate, messenger. So, it's really up to
the translator that changes it. But God
does call Moses God. When we read it,
the translators chose the word God.
Correct.
>> That's not my argument, though. But
we're talking it goes back to Hosea
12:13
Yahweh spec specifically led them out.
>> Right. So, and the reason why that's
important because that represents the
agency.
>> For example, in first Chronicles, who uh
forced David to number the people, Satan
or the most high? depends on actually it
was God technically but the way that
works though Chronicles it says Satan
right
>> well here's the thing though pastor
>> yes or no does it say Satan
>> it says that but you understand Satan
the most high
>> no
can I respond
>> can I respond now
>> yes
>> so in the ancient world in the ancient
world they would attribute God things
that he only passively allowed so in 1
Chronicles 10 Saul commits suicide but
the last verse of that chapter says God
put him to death. So they would So Satan
did it, but God allowed it.
>> But then when you say Satan passively,
right, and here's where Christians have
a struggle because you think Satan
rebelss against him.
>> The Lord told Satan to do it.
>> No, he didn't.
>> Yes, he did. Just like the Lord told
Satan to do that.
>> Where's the verse? I have it in front of
me right now. I I just I just happen to
have it. I have I have it. I can read it
again.
>> I can read it. You ask for the verse, I
can read. You got to make sure you got
to make sure that this is not just a
passive in the cultural context.
>> Let me just read I'm going to read both
because you got one verse in Samuel, one
verse in Chronicles, both saying the
same thing.
>> 1 Chronicles 21-1. And Satan stood up
against Israel and provoked David to
number Israel.
>> Right?
>> 2 Samuel 24:1. And the anger of the Lord
was kindled against Israel, and he moved
David against him.
>> So the Lord was angry with David and
used Satan.
>> He didn't respond to what I said. Okay.
>> You didn't respond to what I said.
>> I did respond to what you said because
Satan the most high aspect. Of course
not. But is
>> why does one So my question why does 2
Samuel 21 24:1 say the Lord and 21 and1
Chronicles 21:1 say Satan?
>> I already answered you.
>> I already answered.
>> Answer it again please. I didn't hear
you.
>> Because in the ancient cultural context,
God when he allowed something, they
would use the active verbal.
>> It's not an allowance. The Lord was
angry with David and the Lord used Satan
to carry out his judgment.
>> Who killed Saul?
>> You tell me.
>> Saul committed suicide.
>> What does that have to do with the most
according to your logic?
>> Well, let's go back to my argument then.
Okay. Okay. So, Yahweh is the most high,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Hosea 12:13, right?
>> Right.
>> Okay. So, then in numbers when he sent
fiery serpents
>> Mhm.
>> was that from Yahweh?
>> Yes. Everything is from
>> Well, then whoa whoa whoa. First
Corinthians 10:9.
>> Bring it out. Do not test Christ as they
tested him in the wilderness. And he
didn't service. Can I get the verse?
>> You just You just said that was Yahweh
>> Christ.
>> I'm asking I'm just asking for the verse
in Corinthians.
>> What?
>> I'm like, you see how I read both
verses? Yeah.
>> I'm asking for the verse in Corinthians.
>> All right, let's read the verse.
>> Right.
>> Bring it out. Let's get the
>> Can you call Can you call out the
scripture, please?
>> I'll start in um I'll start in verse
eight. I'll start verse seven.
>> I'm sorry. Can you just call it out,
please?
>> Yeah. First Corinthians.
>> Uh-huh.
>> So, I'll start in I'll start in verse 7,
then I'll move my way up.
>> Know what chapter you
>> 1 Corinthians 10:7.
>> All right.
>> Do not be do not be idoltors as some of
them were. As it is written, the people
sat down to eat and drink and rose up to
play. Verse 8, we must not indulge in
the sexual immorality as some of them
did, and the 23,000 fell a single day.
Verse N.
>> Uhhuh.
>> We must not put Christ to the test as
some of them did and were destroyed by
serpents.
>> Now, I don't know if y'all even
understand what's happening here before
I respond to the verse.
>> What he's admitting is that Christ is a
part of the agency of the Most High.
>> Why does it say that? Because what you
said, well, we both agree that it was
the most high that um called the fiery
serpents. Right. Right.
>> If I go by your logic, which I do not,
>> but even if I go by your logic, all
you're showing is that the Most High
used Christ at that time. If I go by
your logic,
>> we got a problem. Wait, let me finish
this. Wait, let me just say to the
verses say God used him. It says they we
do not put this is what we do with
Christ. This is what Christian This is
what Christians do with Christ. He had
no problem understanding Moses was used
by the most high to part the Red Sea and
do that. Had no problem saying Satan was
used by the Most High to provoke David.
So it's also the same thing when it
comes to Christ being used by the Most
High. But I disagree, hold on, but I
disagree with your interpretation of
that verse. Because when you read 1
Corinthians 10 and 7, I'm going to read
10 and 9. It says, "Neither let us tempt
Christ, comma, as some of them also
tempted and were destroyed of serpents."
What Moses, excuse me, what Paul is
doing is just making a comparison.
Meaning, let's not be like the
Israelites in the past and t the most
high. Let's not, he's not saying, he is
not saying Christ is the most high that
caused the serpents to come. That don't
even make grammatically. That don't even
make sense.
>> It makes perfect grammatical.
>> No, it does not. No, it does not
>> in the Greek. Yeah. No, it does not make
sense at all. And I told y'all verbs
refer back.
>> I told y'all this was going to be a
semantic argument
>> cuz if Christ is the most high based on
the fiery serpents, then Satan is the
most high because Satan was used by the
Most High to number the children of
Israel. You can't get around it. Here's
the problem. You can't get around it.
Here's the problem. If we go to Hosea
12:13, it says you paid the comparison
to Moses. God Yahweh led them out by
Moses. It doesn't say that in in 1
Corinthians 10. It just says they do not
test Christ as some of them did.
Refer back to Christ. That is basic
grammatical structure in Greek. No, it
does not refer back to Christ at all.
And anybody with I can't believe you did
this. Anybody with basic reading
comprehension knows that when it says
neither let us tempt Christ, who is
that? The people in the city of Corinth.
And then he's using an example of people
that tempted the most high saying let us
not be when it said when it's saying
when it's saying as some of them also
tempted
>> because early
neither as some of them also tempted and
were destroyed of serpents. The most
high did the destroying. But now
remember this debate is is Christ the
most high God? If I go by your logic,
you're just telling me that Christ did
it because the Most High told him to.
Just like Satan did it because the Most
High told him to. Just like Moses did it
because what we can read in the Bible is
that God called Moses God. That's clean
plain on the tables. If I read Wait, did
he call
>> If I read Exodus 7 If I read Exodus
Monologer, guys, hold on. If we if I
read Exodus 7, when you say monologue,
the Bible say, "Let God be true and
every man a liar." So, what's the
problem? What's the problem with reading
the scripture?
>> Do you know what the communication
policy is?
>> No, I don't. You can. Listen,
>> I like when when Christ when Christ
said, "I'm glad he kept it from the wise
and prudent." He does
>> and gave it to babes. I'm just a baby.
You can be wise and prudent, but what
you can't prove is that Jesus is the
most high God.
>> What if he said it?
>> Control it. All right. What language is
the New Testament written in?
>> Greek.
>> Greek. Okay. So, we got to look at what
words in Greek refer to God. Right.
>> Well, before we do that, we have to
understand why Greek was the dominant
language first. Greek was the dominant
language because it was illegal to be a
Jew. It was illegal to be Hebrew because
they were helenized. That's why it's
written in predominant Greek. So, for
example, you can see in 1 Corinthians
8:6 when he calls Jesus Lord,
>> but then you can also read in 1 Peter
3:7 when Abraham is called Lord,
>> they're the same words.
>> But you wouldn't say that Abraham is the
Lord that you going to try to make
Christ. What y'all try to do, there's a
normaly of the Bible, a river that flows
through until we get to Christ and then
y'all make them magical. Are you done?
Listen here. Can I finish? All right.
So, so we got to look at words in Greek
that refer to the most high. Right.
Okay. So, Old Testament written in
Hebrew. Go to places like Psalm 109:21,
it says Adonai Yahweh. Ezekiel 37:21, it
says Adonai Yahweh. That was translated
into the Greek Septuagent. What are they
translated as? Kirk Kitty, Lord, Lord.
>> Now, here's the problem. Here's the
problem. In all the Greek texts from the
time of Jesus and prior, no one no one
calls themselves kitty kitty except one
person.
>> Who that?
>> Jesus. Luke 6:46. He says, "Why do you
call me kitty kitty and not do what I
tell you?
>> Therefore, therefore he is saying I am
Adonai Yahweh." No, he's not.
>> If that if that made sense in John 17
and3 when he says that thou are the one
true God, what you are
>> when listening is an art. And just
because I start with a verse don't mean
I'm coming back not coming back to your
point. That's all I've done. So when
Christ is cutting them on their
ignorance of the title that they're
trying to bestow upon him, Christ never
took a title. But so what he's saying is
why are you calling me? So what he's
saying is if why are you calling me that
and you don't do what I do, he's cutting
them. That's not him declaring that he's
Yahweh. Because John 17 and3 when it
says that thou art the one true God, who
was he talking to
>> when he said, "Thou are the one true
God."
>> Back to the verse. Hold on. I need to
trust what you said. You said
>> he won't read the verse. When y'all say
deal with the verse, he won't read the
verse.
>> Let's go back to Luke 46.
>> Can we read the verse? They are calling
him.
>> Can we read the verse?
>> Yeah, I can read it for you right now.
Luke 6:46. I said I got to memorize. Why
do you call me Lord? Do what I say.
>> But I don't trust you.
>> You can. All right. All right. He's
calling me a liar. Please read how to
memorize.
>> I'm not calling you a liar. But the
reason why I wanted like you see how I
said my explanation was very clear. I
said them calling him that does not mean
he accepted that and then and then he
cut him by saying if I was that why you
don't do what I say return you and your
fans then you and your fans decided to
say I ran from the scripture so I did
answer the whether you disagree or agree
I did answer so now we read Luke you
said 646
>> 646 got
>> now notice in this verse he accepts what
they're calling him and says all Right.
You're calling me Lord. Lord
>> Blessed are
>> Hey, wait. Hold on one second. I got it.
I got it. Everybody relax. I got it. I
got it. Everybody relax. If he's trying
to get through, what's the problem?
>> He was pushing me. Who?
>> He was
the film.
>> Everybody relax.
>> Huh?
>> I'm sorry. Everybody, can everyone just
take a step back? We want to get
everyone recording
essentials. Hey, I'm going to take a
step.
>> If everybody could understand, if
everybody could understand, right? The
people that are filming have to be
everybody. If everybody can shine, which
means listen for a second. If I But
you're not a part of the filming team.
Sis, I'm just trying to explain. I
agree. But what I'm saying is if they're
filming, just let everybody have the
position. I'm not want to go back and
sis and brother. I don't want to go back
and forth with y'all. I just want to
have the debate.
>> Give me a one thing. You can film, but
you don't have to film disrespectfully
and push people. You can say, "Excuse
me,
>> but if he's being pushed because he's
standing there."
>> I have it on film.
>> Can we just continue with this? Can
every Can we all act civilized?
>> Why? I I know y'all savior getting cut.
>> I know y'all savior getting cut, but
let's act civilized. Let's act
civilized. So Luke 6 and46 says Luke
>> Luke 6 and 46 I want to and I want to
point something out JP I just want to
point one thing out
>> somebody's streaming right now on Tik
Tok
>> and and they're live on Tik Tok. So if
you're live on Tik Tok please end that
live again
>> and I want and I want to point something
else out and this is how you know who
savior is winning and who's losing. JP
asked if y'all didn't heckle with saying
the verses and stuff like that. Who's
doing that? The Christians are the
Israelites or not?
>> JP laid the words out and look at God
logic getting out of now. Look at him.
That's what I do to Christians. I'm good
at this. I'm good at this. I got him out
of his body.
>> Let's read the Let's read. All right. No
sweat. All right.
>> Luke 6 and 46. It says, "And why call me
Lord, Lord, and do not the things that I
which I say?" Now, can I read a couple
of verses above?
>> I want you I want you to read the second
one. Read Matthew 7:21. Now,
>> so you don't want me to stay right here.
>> You can read more of it, but I mean,
it's the same thing there.
>> Okay. So, you But it's the same account,
but a different
>> No, it's another It's another It's
another aspect where he's called Lord.
>> Now, now, now, how you do get to do
that? Then they say, "Let's stay on this
one then. Go for it." cuz I'm trying to
see where did they call him lord lord in
here
>> where he says they are says they are
>> remember my position is he's cutting
them
>> his position is he's saying he's god
where in this chapter did they call him
lord
>> he says you're calling me lord lord
great but you're not doing what I say
that's important if you're going to
accept my question
>> you got to do what he says
>> can I get an answer to my question where
in this chapter did he did they call him
Lord for him to say why call me Lord
Lord because
>> are you saying Jesus lied?
>> I'm not saying that. I'm asking you to
show me right. Now
>> people may wonder well Cat why you want
to know that? Because my position is
he's cutting them when he said you
calling me Lord Lord but you're not
doing what I say.
>> You're saying somebody called him Lord.
So show me who called them Lord.
Otherwise my position is correct.
>> It's crazy. Let's do it.
>> Jesus does not.
>> Can you do it? All you got to do is say
yes or no. Somebody call him Lord. Yes
or no?
>> Because I trust Jesus. He said so.
>> Where?
>> Do you not understand how this works?
>> Yes, I do. I know that he's cutting
this.
>> Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Where'd
you get the crown?
>> You know what he's saying?
>> Where'd you get the crown? Where'd you
get the crown?
>> What does that have to do with this?
>> I was just curious. Where'd you get it?
>> You could never get one. Where'd you get
>> You're talking about the crown cuz
you're getting You can never get it.
>> Why
are we talking about my hair? Jesus is
God. Jesus is God. Jesus is Jesus is
God. Jesus is God. Jesus is God. Jesus
is
imitating as usual. Y imitating. You
know what's crazy? Y'all imitating the
Israelites just like y'all imitated the
real true image of Jesus Christ. Just
like y'all imitated our laws. You're
nothing but imitating. Not even
original.
>> He's upset.
>> He's upset when you get loud and then
his people get loud. hypocrites.
>> We can do that. That's the rule. That's
part of the rules.
>> Then don't get don't get upset when they
do it. But
>> I'm not upset. I'm just pointing it out
with
>> Jesus said if Jesus said you're calling
me Lord Lord, he is not lying.
>> Here's what I was told. If somebody
actually called him from the person who
made I can see it there.
>> If somebody actually calls him Lord
Lord,
>> I might give you some credit. But nobody
calls him Lord Lord there. So when he's
saying Lord, Lord, he's cutting them.
He's saying they don't do what he say.
But the subject of this is, is Jesus the
most high God? So as I went to John 17
and three, when Christ said, "You are
the one true God." Paraphrasing, who is
he talking about?
>> He is talking to the father.
>> So did he call the father three gods or
did he call the father one god?
>> I thought you know what we believe. I
thought you knew what we believed.
That's a that's a misconception. No, I
don't care what you believe. The subject
is, is Jesus the most high God? So, if
Jesus has a God,
>> he can't be the most high because there
ain't a God. The whole name, the whole
reason for the name Most High is cuz
there ain't nobody over him.
>> Can I respond now?
>> Yes.
>> All right. Am I interrupted or can I
respond?
>> Well, don't do that cuz we've been
interrupting each other.
>> This is pretty simple. Don't do that.
They get touching. They get when they
get hot, they get touching. They get
touching.
>> This is pretty simple.
>> It ain't working. Scholars have pointed
out the verse does not say only the
father is the true god. It says the
father is the only true god. And what
does the same author said say at the end
of 1 John 5? The son is also true god.
That's right. Therefore he's true god.
John 17:5 he shares in the same glory
with the father claiming equality with
the father. That logically follows. This
is why he can say he's Yahweh in Luke.
I'm not done. Matthew 7:21-22
he says he is Adoni Yahweh. Hebrews 1:3
says he is the exact imprint of the
nature of the father. If the father is
the most high then Jesus is also the
most high cuz he is the exact imprint.
Now
>> when they start when they start running
them smoggage boards that's how you know
they full of crap
>> because in John 17 and3 it says and this
is life eternal that they might know
thee the only true God and and Jesus
Christ whom thou sent. So the only true
God is him. Then he talked about glory.
John 17 and if I was to read this uh 23
it says I in them and thou I'm sorry 22.
And the glory which thou givest me, I
have given them. So I guess if we get
that glory, then we gods, too.
>> We got no because you can't you can't
make it about you can't make it about
>> he's not letting me respond.
>> I want y'all to highlight. Now I don't
care about being interrupted, but this
man said he did not want to be
interrupted as he ran through about six
verses
>> and then what does he do to me?
>> So I don't want to hear nothing when you
when I interrupt you. I don't mind it.
>> But you wanted me to be quiet when I was
good.
>> Thank you. Don't get mad because I check
them. I got to check them. So, John 17
and 21 when it says the glory. Now,
since he ran off Hebrews and other
verses like that, if I was to read the
book of Ephesians, chapter 1 verse1 17.
Hold up, let me find it. I like to read
verses.
>> I don't just like to say verses. Lord,
come back to that. No, it ain't no Lord
Lord. Ephesians 1:17 that the God of our
Lord Jesus Christ
>> That's right.
>> Okay. That's right.
>> So,
>> it says so
God, the God of our, and this is what's
heavy.
>> It says, "The God of our Lord Jesus
Christ, the Father of glory, can only be
that same God that may give unto you the
spirit of wisdom and revelation." So,
Paul clearly says, "The God of our Lord
is Christ." So, he can't be the most
high. You done? Can I go now?
>> Yes. All right. Wait, before you go,
before you go, is this what this going
to be like? No interruptions going
forward. I just want to know.
>> Okay, I can do that if you want to do
that.
>> Okay, but but I we should give respect
to each other, which we was doing before
you got emotional. Go ahead.
>> All right, so let's go back to that.
Okay,
>> so again, I need to go back to what I
said in the beginning here. I stated
that on purpose. We believe Jesus is
subordinate and role to the father.
We've said that, but that does not
affect the substance of God.
>> Exactly. As I said, Hebrews 1:3 says,
"He is the exact imprint of the nature
of the father." Therefore, if the father
is the most high, Jesus is also the most
high. This is why he can say, "I am
Adonai Yahweh." Matthew 7:21, Luke 6:46,
Matthew 7:21, he says, "Not everyone who
comes to me and says, "Lord, Lord will
be entered into the kingdom of heaven."
That's the beginning. You say he's Lord,
Lord, but that doesn't get you in
entirely because you still got to do his
will is what he's going on. So the first
thing you got to do is you got to say,
"Hey, you're clearly Adonai Yahweh."
Then do what he says, and if you do
that, you get in. That's what he's
pointing out. Therefore, he's claiming
to be the most high in his own words.
>> People think that people think that
their position matters in the title of a
debate.
>> The title of the debate is not to
understand what he ignorantly thinks of
the trinity.
>> The title of the debate is to teach is
Jesus the most high God. And so far, we
have not done that. So far we have seen
agency. When Christ raised Lazarus from
the dead, he said, "Father, I'm only
saying this publicly because you hear me
always." Meaning everything that he did,
he prayed and asked the father first.
This is just the first time he's asking
publicly. Why? Because that's his God.
In John 21, he says, "I go to my God and
your God." My father and your father. So
the topic is not your misunderstanding
of the Bible. The topic is is Jesus the
most high God and it has not been
substantiated yet. If I read Psalms 83rd
chapter the last verse it says that thou
whose name alone is Yahawah the most
high over all the earth. That's clean on
paper. Yahawashi ain't mentioned. Jesus
ain't mentioned. Yeshua ain't mentioned.
Ain't nobody mentioned. So the onus is
on you to show where Christ and even I
have a question. And the kingdom of
heaven right now currently
is Christ sitting on God's throne.
>> Yeah. Can you show that? Sure. Let's do
it.
>> Let's go to Revelation. But first, I
want to address what you said there.
When he raised Lazarus, he prayed so
they would know. But then he just said,
"Lazarus, come out." Because he is the
resurrection. As he says in that
chapter, who raises the dead? God. Who
raises the dead in John? Jesus does.
Let's go to Revelation 22.
>> Be careful. That's ugly.
>> Did Peter raise anybody from the dead?
>> Did Peter raise anybody?
>> In the name of Jesus.
>> Did he do it
>> in the name of Jesus? So, is wait, wait,
wait. I'm not I'm not done. I'm not
done. Cuz Elijah raised somebody from
the dead. Not in the name of Jesus.
Elijah raised somebody from the dead. So
don't tell me in the name of Jesus as if
that's the only way you could do it. If
God gives somebody the power, they have
the power. Matter of fact, when Paul
healed that brother, you know what they
did?
>> They called Barnabas Jupiter and they
called him Mercury. You know why?
Because y'all y'all think that y'all
believe that Jesus is God is something
that Christians only believe. That was
the Roman culture that if you did a
miracle, they attributed to Zeus,
Mercury, Venus, however. So y'all
accepting Jesus as God is your norm.
Otherwise, in Acts the 14th chapter,
when Paul healed that person, did they
call him and Barnabas gods? Yes or no?
We got a problem. We are going to the
pagans for our theology now. That is
your theology. That's your theology.
That's your theology. That's your
theology. So again, answer the question.
>> Did they call them gods? Yes or no?
>> The pagans did. Yes.
>> Did the pagans. We don't trust them.
>> Why? Why did they do that? Because they
performed a miracle. And now miracles
are all throughout the Bible. Moses did
a miracle. Elijah did a miracle.
Everybody did miracles. Y'all are pagan
because everybody else says that God
used them to do his miracles. You pagans
come and say Jesus did it because he's
the most high God. Instead of listening
when Christ say the works I do are from
my father. Everything he did was cuz the
father gave him the ability to do so. So
you're pagan.
>> That's right.
>> We got a problem because you said John
11 he prayed to God to resurrect him. I
had to correct you because he doesn't do
that. He prays and then he resurrects
him with his own power. That's what I
was pointing out.
>> Why would you correct him again? John 11
when he resurrects Lazarus, he just
says, "Lazarus, come forth." He doesn't
say, "God, bring Lazarus forth." That's
what I was correcting for you.
>> No, that's horrible because he said,
"You hear me always." You know why
Yahawashi said, "You hear me always?"
Because he's always talking to him.
>> It's just the first time that he was
talking to him. So everybody could hear.
So he now when he would normally do a
miracle, he would say, "Pop, let me get
this miracle done." He would do it. He
wouldn't say it out loud. This was the
first time that before he did the
miracle.
>> Can I read it?
>> Yes. After. Oh, it's
>> I'm surprised you want to read
scripture.
>> Now, now you want to read scripture. It
says, "Father, I thank you that you have
heard me. I know that you always hear
me. But I said, but I said this on
account of the people standing around me
that they may believe that you sent me."
He doesn't pray for the miracle. He
prays for the people around him so that
they believe that the father has sent
him. The miracle just says, "Lazarus,
come out." That's it. Why does he say
you hear me always?
>> Why does he say that? Because the father
hears us always. He's omnic.
>> No, no, no, don't say no us. This ain't
about us. This is about Yahawasha. Why
does he say you hear me always?
>> Because he's on mission. He can hear
everything.
>> What? What?
>> He's omnicient.
>> That's pretty obvious.
>> Your man's dying. He's dying right now.
Why does it say Why does Christ say you
hear me always? There's only one answer.
See? Go ahead. Go ahead. Because he's
always talking to him. Right.
>> And when you say that Christ don't pray,
>> that's a lie.
>> I didn't say that.
>> So then Christ does pray.
>> Of course Christ prays.
>> And he then he prays to himself, to the
most high without the people knowing,
right?
>> That's modalism, Patrick.
>> But modalism. Oh my god. When Christ
prays, modalism is crazy work because
Christ is not a modalist, right? When
Christ is praying to the fathers because
they're two separate beings. So, but
don't let let's not get away from the
point
>> when he said that. That's the proof that
he prayed to the father before he did
any miracles. This was just the first
time that he prayed in front of
everybody.
>> Well, I got a question now. I got a
question. Okay. So, you said that before
he did miracles, he always prayed,
>> but
>> he would always speak to the father to
be clear.
>> Okay, I got you.
>> Which is the same thing.
>> I got you. I get what you're saying. So
according to him we what we see in John
11 is that Jesus would always pray and
then he extrapolates from that and says
well this was this applies to all
miracles but when we were in Luke 6:46
earlier and Jesus says why do you call
me Lord Lord but not do what he say he's
like I don't see anybody saying that
therefore it never happened do you see
the devil standard here play from John
11 and say Jesus is always praying
before miracles but when Jesus says in
Luke 6:46 you're calling me Lord Lord he
says that doesn't work because I didn't
hear anybody say
>> oh I get it now double standard I get
No, no, I didn't. So, let me show you
why I'm superior to this white man.
>> In that verse, it says
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Superior. Superior.
>> Hey, before I answer, hey, hey, before
Hey, before before I answer, give all
y'all a hand. Y'all great ass crowd.
Both sides. You Christians and
Israelites, y'all are great. But here's
the difference between you and I. You
couldn't show me the reason why he was
saying Lord, Lord. In John the 11th
chapter, the reason why Christ said, I
um I say this, you hear me always?
Because they had faith. They didn't have
the faith. Remember Lazarus is dead. And
what do they say? Martha, I think it's
Martha or Mary says, "If you was here,
he would have been alive. He wouldn't
have died." So when he says you hear me
always, I'm not juxtaposing. I'm not
hypothesizing. He said out of his mouth,
you hear me always. And so we can hear,
we can see in other instances where he
prays to the father and the father hears
him. Where he speaks to the father and
the father hears him. So if he's
speaking to the father before he does
the thing that he does, he's not the
most high God.
>> Question. Hold on. Hold on. Oh, hold on.
We'll say something. So So first of all,
I want to say first I want to say in the
name of Jesus, I am not your superior. I
love you as a brother.
>> We are called to love everyone here.
>> That's your Jesus.
>> And there is neither.
We are all one in Christ. I want to
point that out here. Second of all,
second of all, second of all, you are
going on what Jesus said. He said
himself. He said himself, "The father
always hears me." But in Luke 6:36 when
he says, "You call me Lord, Lord." Now,
we can't trust Jesus. We can trust him
there, but we can't trust his word when
he says they're calling. This is a
double standard.
>> No, it's not.
>> No, it's not. No, it's not.
>> All I All I asked him, I never
questioned what Christ said. I agreed
with what Christ said.
>> I'm just talking about the context that
Christ said it. He was cutting them. His
context is somebody called him Lord. So,
I'm calling him out on his bull crap
because he can't show in that verse
where, excuse me, in that chapter that
somebody called him Lord. I'm not
questioning Christ. I'm questioning your
understanding because it's horrible.
>> So, let's go.
>> Don't question. So, let's go to the
Matthew then. Matthew 7:21 cuz you Okay,
then after you ask your question, I got
a question.
>> Okay, you got it. So, okay. He says in
22, he says, "On that day, many will say
to me, Lord, Lord, did we not prophesy
your name and cast out demons?" 7:22.
Sorry. 7:22 here we have people saying
he is Lord Lord in Matthew 7:22 he says
on that day many will say Lord Lord did
we not prophesy in your name did we not
cast out demons in your name and do many
mighty works in your name so they're
calling him Lord Lord there
once again once once again Christ is
saying many men so he's paraphrasing so
I can give you a actual living example
of that when Paul and Peter as they're
doing their miracles I think it's Acts
the 19th chapter
The Pharisees see the miracles that they
doing and then they try to cast out the
demon. What did they say? What did they
say? But read it. They said, "We cast
you out in the Jes in Paul's Jesus or
Peter's Jesus." I believe that's the
term that they say. And when they say
that,
>> the demon beats them up. Correct.
>> Well, why don't we read it?
>> Let's get those We're not sure right
now. The reason why we're the reason why
we're reading that, the reason why we're
I'm saying that is because the Lord Lord
is not saying he's the most high. Here's
what happens when y'all read and and get
stuck on the Greek and linguistics. And
this why when we before we started,
Christ said, "I'm glad he kept it from
the wise and prudent, but gave it unto
babes."
>> 30 minute warning. 30-minute warning.
>> Thank you. Appreciate it. And that's it.
It's only been 30 minutes. So when we
look at that the Lord Lord is not him
declaring that he's the most high
because everything we do today is in
Christ's name. Even Christians when they
pray y'all say in the name of Jesus.
Even Israelites when we pray we say in
the name of Jesus because he's the
mediator of the New Testament.
>> Before Christ we would do everything
according to Moses. Moses was the
mediator before Christ. So when you say
that Lord, Lord, that's all that it is.
>> Hold on. Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute. It would
be blasphemy to say in the name of Moses
because he's not God.
>> That's not the point. Y'all are so y'all
are so literal you can't even understand
it. So I So I'll give you an example.
I'll give you an example of doing
everything. The laws. Who delivered the
laws?
>> Moses delivered the law.
>> Why did he deliver the laws?
>> Because he was the mediator of the old
covenant.
[Applause]
Come on youus.
>> Hey, wait. I want I want everybody to
pay attention. I want everybody to pay
attention. Wait, wait, wait. I want I
want everybody to pay attention. Go.
>> When I made the statement, if I could,
if I could, I'll kill him. If I could,
when I said we do everything in Christ's
name because he's the mediator of the
New Testament, just like Moses is the
mediator of the Old Testament, all the
Christians said it was like it was
blasphemy.
>> Then I asked him, then I asked him, I
said, "Who delivered the law?" He said,
"Moses." I said, "Why?" I didn't even
think he was going to say that. He said
because he was the mediator of the whole
company,
>> you died.
>> So here we got a problem.
>> So So my my point So my problem So yeah,
you died. You died.
I got to keep I got to keep explaining
to you what we believe because you keep
misrepresenting our beliefs.
>> It's not about what you believe. You
know this. You know this when you went
Hold up. Hold up. Just hold up. Here's
the problem. Here's the problem.
>> I said in the beginning of this Jesus is
ontologically God, but he is subordinate
in role. Yeah. His role of the covenant.
So what? That doesn't change ontology.
That was not a point. You didn't even
understand the point.
>> Hey cryb babies over there. We're all
subordinate. We're all subordinate in
role. When it says the head of Christ is
God, it's not just that he's
subordinate. He don't sit on that
throne. In Revelations,
who comes before the throne? The lamb,
right? The lamb does. And then he's in
the center. Where is God?
>> And then who's sitting on the throne?
>> God is. And the lamb is there, too.
>> The lamb is there, too.
>> So, so you that that's a good answer.
The angel said in Luke the first
chapter, when the angel was talking to
Mary, whose throne was Christ prophesied
to?
>> You want me to read? You want me to read
for you something?
>> That's up to you. But what I'm saying
is, well, you already agree with me that
that God is sitting on the throne. The
lamb is before the throne.
>> The angel in Luke the first chapter,
whose throne did the angel say Christ is
going to sit on?
>> He's going to sit on the He's going to
sit What? He sit on the throne of his
David. So what?
>> He going to sit. So So is God. Wait,
wait, wait. Wait, wait. So is the Most
High sitting on David's throne?
>> No.
>> Is Christ s Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Is Wait, wait, wait. Is
Christ sitting on David's throne?
>> Christ is on David's throne.
>> So those two different thrones, right?
Wait. So those two different thrones,
right?
>> There's two thrones because there's two
persons of the same.
>> So there's a throne that belongs to the
most high and there's a throne that
belong to the
>> Where is that throne though?
>> Wait, I'm I'm just asking the question.
>> Let me read
after after you answer this. Wait, wait.
After you answer this question,
>> after you answer this, I'm going to read
Wait before you read it. No, I I'll give
you the floor. I just want to say that.
So you you agree that there's a throne
that the Most High is sitting on and
there's a throne that Christ sitting on,
but they're not the same throne.
>> No, I do not agree.
>> Okay. You No, I said I said I would let
you go.
>> Okay. So let's go to the end of
Revelation 22. Okay, this is important.
This is important because don't do it.
This is important. Don't do it. Don't do
it.
>> The reason why this is important.
>> This is the reason why this is important
is because throughout the Bible, we see
that only God gets worship. We're going
to read a couple verses.
>> Okay?
>> Only gets this type of worship called
Luo. Luo is for God. It says, let's
start in verse uh two throughout the
middle city on either side of the river,
the tree of life with its 12 kinds of
fruit yielding its fruit each month. The
leaves of the trees were for the healing
of the nations. No longer will there be
anything accursed, but the throne of God
and the lamb will be in it. And his
servants will let him worship him. They
will see his face and his name will be
on their foreheads and night will be no
more. They will need no light, lamp or
sun. For the Lord God will be their
light and they will reign forever and
ever. So in there the lamb and god are
being worshiped as luo. The true O is
worship only for God.
>> So, so I'm going respond.
>> So, in Revelations
22,
>> so in Revelations 22, I'm going to get
right to the meat where it says um I
think you did three.
No, the parts where it says the throne
of God was three and then six when it
says um and there shall be no more
curse, but the throne of God and the
lamb shall be in it. That's the
important thing, right? So, you you
agree that God Christ is sitting on them
with with his throne, too?
>> They're both being worshiped. Yeah.
>> Wait, I I ain't get to the worship part
yet, but what I'm asking you is that God
and Christ both thrones is on top of
each other.
>> What?
>> What? On top of each other?
>> I I know. I know it's hard. I know it's
hard. Revelation. I know it's hard
because now here's the problem. And
here's why here. Thank you. It's a
vision, right?
>> It's a vision. Yeah.
>> Right. So when it says in it, it doesn't
mean it's literally that Christ is
literally on the throne. It's a metaphor
of his position. Right.
>> Exactly.
>> Thank you. Got you.
God. So if it's not literal, then Christ
is not literally sitting on the throne
with the father because the angel said
he's getting the throne of his father
David. So there'll be a throne that
Christ sits on and then there'll be a
throne. And you look at that smile. Cut
it. Then there'll be a throne. Then then
there'll be a throne that God sits on.
Like Revelations 3:21 when it says,
"They that overcome will sit with me in
my throne the same way I sit with my
father in his throne." It's what you
earn for obeying the most high. When it
comes to worship in 1 Chronicles 29,
>> did they not worship the king too?
>> No.
>> Not Lat.
[Applause]
That wasn't in Greek. That's not
>> You say Latril.
>> Latril. What did Christ say and when he
was getting tempted in the wilderness?
>> Who did he say to worship?
>> In Matthew, he says you worship God
alone and he used Latro,
>> right?
>> Matthew.
>> So Christ said you worship him alone,
>> right?
>> You're saying we worship God and Christ
the same.
>> Well, I'm just reading the scripture.
I'm just reading. Listen, all I'm saying
see like see like when we talk about the
Bible, if Christ says you worship God
alone, Latrao, like you said,
>> you clearly don't know what Revelations
22, you already admitted admitted that
it's a vision. So now when we actually
read it,
>> when it says God and the lamb, that's a
clear separation between them two.
That's right.
>> That's why in Revelation, right, cuz in
Revelations the 5th chapter, God sits on
that throne by himself. There is nobody
on the throne with him at all. That's
why the lamb that like Christ post death
>> is still not on the throne. That's
right.
>> You know why he's not on the throne?
Because we're waiting for him to return
and have the rulership on the throne of
David.
>> True or false?
>> True or false? He's standing on the
right hand of God.
>> Let me respond.
>> You can't say it's false, Logic. Can't
say it. Look. Look. Let me respond. So
he said okay he said okay
>> he said it's a vision but we also know
the scriptures say that Jesus is the
visible image of the invisible God. God
is not literally sitting on a throne in
heaven as he said it's a vision but
they're both there in the center
receiving the true worship. That's
important sitting on a throne worship.
That's what's important there and
heaven. He admitted it. He admitted
Matthew Jesus says you should only
worship Latru God alone. Right.
>> So Jesus says that but then in
revelation but there's nothing they're
both getting material worship.
They're not they're not that's your
misunderstanding of the verse because
when it comes to worship you can worship
the king because that's who God set up.
So there's no issue with worship. So I
can't help it if y'all don't understand
what Revelations 22 means. When it says
God and the lamb, they're not getting
it. Even if I go back to Revelations 5
at the end of the chapter, it says the
same thing. So Revelations 5 says, "And
every excuse me, and the four beasts
said, Aman, and the four and 20 elders
fell down and worshiped him." I'm sorry,
let me read the verse before that. Verse
13. And every creature which is in
heaven and earth, and under earth, as
such as are in the sea, and all them
heard, I say, "Blessed, honor, and glory
be unto him that siteth upon the throne,
and unto the Lamb." Exactly.
>> So I don't have a problem. The argument
is not worship.
>> The argument is is Christ the most high.
>> But
>> just because God allows the king to get
worship, which we can read in 1
Chronicles. So if I go to 1 Chronicles,
where you at?
>> First, where you at?
>> In 1 Chronicles 29, it says uh 29 and
20. It says, "And David said to all the
congregation, now bless the Lord your
God. And all the congregation blessed
the Lord, the God of their fathers, and
bowed down their heads and worship the
Lord and the King."
>> That's right.
>> So they worshiped the King in the Old
Testament.
>> So So is in heaven. In heaven is God the
Lord of Jesus.
>> Yes.
>> He's the Lord of Lords, right?
>> Now read uh Revelation 17:14 for me.
>> Well, you can read it.
>> You want me to read it? Oh, I'll gladly
read it. Yeah. still know
>> Revelation 17:14. He just said,
>> you said you said
>> 17:14, he just said, "In heaven, God the
Father is the Lord of Lords." But what
does this verse say? They will make war
on the lamb and the lamb will conquer
them for he is lord of lords and king of
kings.
>> You said 17. You said 17.
>> 17:14.
>> Thank you. So now when we read
when it says, "These shall make war with
the lamb and the lamb shall overcome
them." Where is that war taking place?
>> The war? Yeah. Where where's the war
taking place? You're deviating from it.
That's I'm in the verse.
>> I'm in the verse. No. No. You can't say
that. I'm in the verse. Where?
Revelation 17:14 says they these shall
make war with the lamb and the lamb
shall overcome them. That's talking
about here on earth. Okay. So when
Christ come here, he is going to be lord
of lords and kings of kings on the
earth. He's not. There ain't no war in
heaven where God is at that he's going
to be lord and lords of. It don't apply.
Now that's your scripture.
>> So here's the problem. The Greek is
present tense. It is not future tense.
He
>> So you saying it happened already?
>> Lord of lords always.
>> So you saying so you saying it happened
already?
>> No, I'm saying it's present.
>> So if it ain't happen if it ain't
happened yet, then Christ has to first
go to war here
>> and then win here and then he's going to
be Lord of lords here. You know why he's
going to be? You know why he's going to
be lord of lords here and king of kings
here? Because Revelations 5:10 says a
nation of kings and priests going to
come out of Israel. So there's going to
be other kings, but he's going to be the
king of kings. But in heaven, there's
one king that's the most high. So if I
read Micah 5, Micah 5 and2, it says,
"But thou Bethlehem Ephra,
>> though thou be little among the
thousands of Judah, yet out of these
shall come forth unto me is to be a
ruler in Israel." We would agree, let's
talk about Christ, whose going forth
have been of old from everlasting.
Therefore will I give them up until the
time that which he traveth and have
bought forth. Then the remnant of his
brethren shall return unto the children
of Israel, and he shall stand and feed
in the strength of the Lord in the
majesty of the name of the Lord his
God.
>> Now, that's important. I'm glad you
brought that up. That's important
because Jeremiah 32 says, "God is God is
God of all flesh." Now, when Jesus took
on flesh, he therefore he's got he's
flesh now. Therefore, he's got to have a
God who's the father because the
scriptures cannot be broken. Therefore,
of course, he's got a God.
>> So, let's focus on God, y'all. We've
never disputed that as trinitarian.
We've This is why I opened my thing and
said, "Hey." Hey, but again, going back
Deuteronomy 10:17 says, "Yahweh is Lord
of Lords."
>> Revelation 17:14 says, "Jesus is Lord of
Lords. Therefore, Jesus is God." Right?
So, now on the subject of God, now
remember the debate is not the debate is
not is Jesus God or can people be God?
But on the subject of God, this is
Zechariah 12:8. In that day shall the
Lord In that day shall the Lord defend
the inhabitants of Jerusalem, and he
that is feeble among them at that day
shall be as David. And the house of
David shall be as God.
>> Now, now we got like we going to have a
subject of God. Jesus ain't going to be
the only one that's going to be God. It
says, "The house of David shall be as
God as the angel of the Lord before
them. So even the title of calling
somebody God is not something that's
synonymous with Christ.
>> We don't found out Moses was called God,
Satan is called God. We don't find a
bunch of people called God.
>> So but the debate is not that.
>> But the debate is is Jesus the most high
God? We have not. All we've read is
verses that Christ says he has a God and
then my opponent tries to philosophy
trinitarian belief that just don't line
up. We got to go back to the verses you
keep running from. If he is Lord of
lords in Revelation 17:14, but Yahweh is
Lord of lords in Deuteronomy 10:17.
Therefore, he is the most high. I've
given you verse after verse. Matthew
7:21-22, Luke 6:46. I can go to Mark,
for example, 2:28 as well. We got
Revelation 17:14. We got Revelation 22
where he sees Latru. You said, "I've not
given you." I've given you several
verses and instead of actually
addressing them, you just go to other
verses where you show Jesus's
subordinate role. That fits with our
position. You're telling us our position
and we're going, "Yeah, yeah, that's not
a problem." That doesn't deal with the
onlogical verses like Hebrews 1:3, which
I brought up as well, where he is the
exact imprint of the nature of God.
Therefore, he is most high. That
>> That's not That's not true. Wait, wait,
don't do that. Don't That's That's not
true. But when you say I don't address
your verses, you're being extremely
dishonest. Like if I take Revelation
17:14, I went right there and did I not
ask you where was that war taking place?
Yes or no?
>> Yes, you did.
>> And then did I give my position that the
war was going to take place here on
earth and he's Lord of lords here, king
of kings here? Yes or no?
>> You did. But the problem
>> and then did I also revelations 5 and 10
when we'll be a nation of kings and
priests. So when it says lord of lords,
king of kings cuz there's other kings on
earth, then don't say I didn't answer
your question. The problem don't be a
liar here. Don't be a liar. Cuz I'm now
I'm calling you a liar. The problem is
I'm calling you a liar.
>> You say the white man is the devil.
That's why because you're saying I
didn't answer and I clearly answered
your question. Don't do that.
>> I don't like being called a liar.
>> I never called you a liar.
>> You just said I didn't answer your
question, but you just agreed that I
just answered your Revelation 17:14.
That is the epitome of a liar. Don't do
that. You can disagree with me. Just
don't call me a liar.
>> Listen, Cap. Saying things
>> like we've been lied enough by white
people. Saying things,
>> saying things is not addressing my
points. I'm reflecting by talking about
the war. And I pointed out in response
to you in Revelation 17:14,
>> I just showed how you didn't know. It's
present tense. But we disagree, not that
he will be.
>> But you said I didn't answer it. I did
answer it. It'd be one thing if you say
I disagree with his answer. But to say I
didn't answer, you're calling me a liar.
And I don't play that. Don't do that. My
point is though, my point is if you're
going to say stuff, you need to address
my point.
>> I did. You want that Lord of Lords. You
said in heaven. I asked you where the
war take place and you wouldn't answer.
You didn't answer that. Where does the
war take place?
>> Takes place on earth. So what
>> you said Lord of Lords in heaven. The
verse that you pulled, you just admitted
takes place on earth. So when it's
called of Lord of Lords, it's on earth,
not in heaven. So now we see once you
expose the white man as the devil, you
get the truth. That's what we need.
That's all we want. Christ said, "Ye
shall know the truth and the truth shall
make you free."
>> This is nasty work. Logic. Logic.
>> You done?
>> Logic. Make somebody better. This nasty
work, right? You know it, too. I'm going
talk to you on the side.
Get his face. Get his face. He knew it.
He know nasty one
>> again. Again, again, we cannot
Revelation warns, do not add to this
book. What we are seeing here,
Revelation 17:14, he's saying, "Well,
you're Lord of Lords on earth." It
doesn't say that he is Lord of Lords.
Why are you adding to the verse? That is
a danger. I didn't add to the verse. I
just said where the verse taking place.
Revelations 22:16. In heaven, is he the
root offspring of David?
You asking the question
>> all this whole time. Now, now he don't
know if it's a question or not. Now he
don't know. Son, he don't know if it's a
question or not.
>> You asking me a question or you being
>> I said Revelations 22:16. Is he the ruin
offspring of David?
>> Let's read it. 22:16.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. That's like one of the
last chapters when you was like he God
or something like that like he was God
or something like that. He said I'll
read it. Go.
>> Go. You go. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Oh, no problem. I Yahawah have
sent mine angel to testify unto you
these in the churches. I am the root
>> and offspring of David. This is after he
died. So yes, the most is the most high
from David.
>> Yes.
Let me tell y'all something, man.
>> Can I respond now?
>> Indoctrination.
>> Indoctrination is a mother scooter. Can
I respond now?
>> Of course.
>> Okay. All right. Once again, we've
already established Jesus claims to be
Adonai Yahweh, Lord of Lords, King of
Kings. He claims to be Yahweh. He says
it directly in Matthew 7:2122,
Luke 6:46. Therefore, when he took on
flesh, as we saw, the most high is now
has two natures. He's got a human
nature. He is fulfilling the role of
king as well. This is not hard.
>> Okay?
>> Um, very simple. There's no verse,
there's no verse, there's no verse in
the Bible that says the most high has
two nations. I'm just two natures.
There's not one single verse in the
Bible that says the Most High has two
natures. Look at them. Ain't none of my
Hey, ain't none of my people. Y got a
verse. Ain't none of my people.
>> 50 minute mark. We're going to do five
minute closings and then finish. Good.
Yeah. Okay. Okay.
>> I went first so he can go first. No, you
go first, man. You go.
>> No, you go first. I went first the first
time.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's the way debates work.
You go first. I go last.
>> No, I mean you went first. I went first
with the opener. So, you go first.
>> That's how that's how debates work. If
you go first, the other person goes
last.
>> That's That's basically
>> I don't know if I need the whole I I
I'll go first. Listen, let me let me
tell you something. I've been whooping
his butt. I got to say butt and sucker
cuz the Christians they get touchy over
logic. Right.
>> Beating his ass.
>> My man. Give a hand. Give a hand. Shout
out to Setta. That's why I bought him.
So, I want everybody I want everybody to
be clear. I want everybody to be clear.
I my I give I give my opponent, you
know, good debate, you know, in the
heated debates, you have a debate. Um,
after the debate is over, that's it. Um,
but this debate clearly showed that
Christ is not the most high,
>> right?
>> I clearly showed I clearly showed Yeah,
I got you. I ain't going to need the
whole five minutes. I clearly showed
that Christ, Moses, Satan, everybody
works through agency of obeying the most
high. He gives the orders. Christ obeys
the orders. There is no verse that he
has presented that said Christ is the
most high. All he did was give a verse
and try to antlogically explain it to
make it mean that. And I think that's
clean and clear. There's so many
different positions where he agreed with
me that I think it's clean. So, I don't
need the rest of the time. I know it's
already late. So, I appreciate y'all
rocking with me.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Thank you. If y'all want
to find me, I am Captain Tazar of ISUPK
under Commander Jennana. You can find me
on Captain Tazar TV. We got a cookout at
Thomas Jefferson Park, April, excuse me,
August 30th, 31st. Make sure y'all come
out there. That's open to all my people
and my people only. And with that, I say
shalom form. All
right, listen. I just want to point
something out here. There's a great
conversation. I appreciate the invite.
Appreciate very intelligent man here. I
just want to say something though. I let
my arguments do the talking. I didn't
have to keep telling you I'm winning
because I know the arguments work. You
guys, if you got to tell me, if you got
to tell me you're winning, you are
worried you're not. Okay. What did we
establish? Jesus says, "I am Adonai
Yahweh." In Matthew 7 and Luke 6, he
says he is Lord of Lord. It says he's
Lord of lords in Revelation 17:14. He is
not that he will be, not that he is just
on earth, that he is presently
everywhere. We also establish that 1
Corinthians 10:9 that Christ is who led
them out of Egypt. Jude 15 is who led
them out of Egypt. Over and over again,
we can point to places where Jesus is
clearly most high. At the end of the
day, Hebrews 1:3, he is the exact
imprint. All we can see here is that we
can see verses where Jesus is
subordinate in role. We agree he's
subordinate in we agree. But that
doesn't address the places where it
shows he is onlogically God. Therefore,
he is the most high at the end of the
day.
>> That's right.
It wasuses.
[Applause]
>> All right, we're going to start
preparing for the next debate.
Enforcables.